let's get back to the phones at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 where do we want to go today
there are so many people holding who
want to talk let's try our caller from
the eight-six 4 area code who's calling
today from 864 hello yeah that's you
hey I want to get your opinion David
about what how do you think that Nancy
Pelosi is currently conducting the
impeachment hickory right because I have
a couple of criticisms that I'd like to
mention I just want to know what your
opinions are because you know recently
Nancy Pelosi she just launched the well
she decided to formally launch a
impeachment resolution right right and
so my problem with that is is that it
feels like she's constantly making
concessions to the Republicans because I
feel like there was an equally valid
reason on both sides of the spectrum
right because if she had she could have
just thought where's the with the idea
that there is no need for due process in
the impeachment inquiry right because
it's not a criminal prosecution right
and if she had just stuck with that then
I feel like she would have I feel like
she would have looked a lot stronger
then now that she's launching the
resolution because I feel like she
doesn't gain anything and she was going
to do that she should have done it from
the very beginning so actually on this I
disagree with you I think there's lots
of fair criticisms of Nancy Pelosi I
think that this is fine listen there was
a pre impeachment inquiry phase during
which witnesses potential witnesses were
being interviewed Trump was not involved
in that he alleged he wasn't being given
due process and that it was unfair but
we are now at the this always happens
this happened in the Clinton impeachment
inquiry as well now they are they are
formalizing the bounds of the inquiry
the president is getting due process I
don't at all think that it weakened
Nancy Pelosi's position to do that and
in fact I think that as Trump content
used to say that it's unfair and there's
no due process even though now it's been
outlined I think it actually makes Trump
look worse and worse so I think I'm okay
with the way Nancy Pelosi handled that
particular thing okay so let me ask you
what do you think that why do you think
like couldn't you have just done that
from the very beginning right why do you
say what is the benefit of going back
and doing it now as opposed to doing it
at the beginning right because now she's
giving the she's giving the right a
munition in order to say that okay we
would write the entire time it feels
like she's making a confession that's
where I disagree with you I listen you
it's normal that there's a priam there's
a pre formalization phase and then you
formalize it I don't think she's giving
the right anything and again I think the
right is going to be exposed as as
completely not credible in their
criticisms because they will continue to
say that they're not getting due process
and that it's all unfair even though now
it's been fertilized so I'm not yeah
here's my concern about there's two two
concerns I have about impeachment number
one are Democrats actually going to get
any of the Trump people to play ball
with document subpoenas or with showing
up because if they don't then a lot a
lot you know the public hearings that
are supposed to be what convince people
that there's been a lot of wrongdoing
aren't going to be effective that's
concern number one and then concern
number two I've seen arguments on both
sides but I'm concerned about how narrow
the scope is of the impeachment inquiry
I would like it I would like it to be
wider but there's conflicting views yeah
yeah that's the next thing I was going
to mention so so I think we're on the
same page at least in regards to that
that you know narrowing down this
impeachment inquiry right to just the
Ukraine transcript and you know the
potential quid pro quo between the Trump
administration and and Ukraine is I mean
this is do you agree that least that
much is maybe not great political tactic
yes yes I don't think I needed to
include you know there's people who are
saying oh they should have done the
Russia collusion it's like no no no
listen that that's that's pretty toxic
at this point and I actually think it's
the right reason it's the right
decision not to include that but
financial crimes Yemen I mean there's
much more that could be part of this
that's not and I do think that that is a
bit concerning but I've read some pretty
good pieces that say it's the right
decision to narrow it we'll see how it
plays out right I mean in the end we'll
just have to wait and see
listen it sounds like you're crinkling
paper onto your headset your handset so
I'm gonna let you go but I really
appreciate the call okay all right good
oh and there he goes all right